Like I said, that's the end of
the work we're going to do on
sort of direct motion.
So basically we've looked at two
generally different ways of doing this,
of doing motion estimation
between two frames.
One can, that can handle
sort of large range sparse,
we find particular features and
we come up with descriptors.
Then we find them in the, second image.
We think we know which
matches are right.
We guess to see which
pairings are correct.
Look for a motion model,
and maps them across.
And that works well.
We can have lots of differences
between the points, but
we have to have a consistent
model across them.
And then we do that ransack thing, etc.
The other method are much more direct or
optic flow or
spatial temporal methods where pixels
may be deforming in a variety of ways.
We've got some patch going one way,
another patch doing another,
maybe a patch is stretching,
twisting, whatever.
And we're going to use the idea
that we can take spatial and
temporal derivatives in order
to tell how things are moving.
You know, one way of thinking about
is that the first method is good for
movement of tens of pixels, so things
move a lot and they may have changed.
So I take a picture over here and take
a picture over there of the same thing,
and I want to figure
out which one is which.
Okay?
The motion ones are better when things
are moving a small amount, you know,
less than ten p, a small amount of
motion, but maybe lots of frames.
So like in a movie when you see nice,
smooth motion between something,
that's when you would think about
the direct optical flow of methods.
So now you have,
sort of in your tool kit, a variety of
ways of computing motion between frames.